SPEAKER: When it
comes to the cloud,
there's more than one
way to serve a file.
In this episode of
Cloud Storage Bytes,
we walk you through all the ways
to serve data from the cloud
so you can determine what the
best fit is for your needs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You can use cloud storage to
serve assets to your customers.
And depending on
your application,
you might need different
methods of getting that data out
of a cloud storage bucket.
You know you've got options, so
let's go ahead and take a look.
First, we've got
client libraries.
If you need to download
assets directly
to your existing
application, this
is something for you to explore.
And trust me when I say
we speak your language.
From C++ to Ruby, check out the
linked documentation for more.
And up next you have
the gsutil application.
Gsutil is a Python
application that
lets you access cloud storage
from the command line.
And, for example,
running this command
will download from a
cloud storage bucket
to a local path on your device.
And like any
awesome tool, gsutil
comes with a plethora
of options to configure
to your specific use
case, like the dash m
command, which allows for copy
options to occur in parallel.
You can also go directly
to the REST APIs
using other programs like Curl
to fetch your files directly
and allowing the user
to log in with oauth.
And, finally, you can
always access your objects
right from the cloud console.
Simply select the
desired bucket or object,
click Save As in the
handy dropdown menu.
This is a great way to
grab individual files
when you're debugging or
going through things manually.
Retrieving files is
really just the start
as there's so much more you
can do with cloud storage,
but that's for another episode.
Subscribe, give
us a like, and let
us know what features
of cloud storage
you'd like to learn more about.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick bite of cloud storage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]